here we are at CES 2012 and we found a
fun series of games called app gear
these games are cool because they
augment more reality bringing virtual
gameplay into the real world there's a
few different games in film fighters
you're a wool bro one fighter pilot and
planes are coming at you and you've got
to shoot them there's another game where
you've got to shoot robots that are
popping out from the ceiling behind
people and the crowd and there's another
game where you have collectible aliens
and you play them kind of like a board
game on your iPad these guys aren't a
big investment there are only ten or
twenty dollars and it's pretty fun